desu
is an asian first-person shooter about
rival assassins
locked in the time loop this is our
unique vision
what arcane is all about free-form
immersive gameplay
a surreal player driven story smashed
together
want to see some stylish action check
this out
[Music]
site and forth in perpetuity your
assistance is appreciated
and mandatory the real party doesn't
start until he's
dead she is
not making this easy
so
it's called
[Music]
good morning black reef another day
another death
our time looks fun
for everyone else on this island this
place is paradise
a never-ending party where hunting me is
the main attraction
and no matter how i try to escape
they always cut me down but i'm
once dubbing [ __ ]
[Music]
every loop i'm learning a little more
piecing together the puzzle
there's eight targets and they all gotta
die before midnight
there's just one little snag
[Music]
you thought it was going to be easy
juliana blake black reef's protector
and a real pain in my ass she may kill
me a million times
but eventually inevitably
i will break this
[ __ ] loop
[Music]
down
[Music]
i don't like watching you die i like
killing you
there's a difference